in many european countries like here in
belgium the trade unions are calling for a
strategy of austerity is there a
way out of this crisis
for years austerity was considered the ultimate solution
but whether this actually
brought positive results remains
friendly just as questionable are the
billions in investments
that have been announced we have viewer questions to the german
delegate michael
theurer and asked how he assesses the situation
the first question we have from business
europe and thus almost rankings treasury
for many member states implementation of
structural funds is revealed watch the
micro studio is if you really
parliament play in the provincial
implementation on the  ripping semester
so what role can parliament
actually
play there? parliament only has indirect
influence, namely on the commission,
which is very busy for us how
can
we avoid the euro getting into such a difficult situation again, that
's a bummer  individual member
states undermined the stability of the currency through an expansive fiscal policy at the expense of others
and that is exactly why
the european semester was introduced,
but many would like to take a
closer look, for example
france because it was the start of the game but
deficits are still not as great
as stated  still gives through
if some are now demanding that the
economic crisis be fought with new debts
, at least we liberals ask ourselves
how do we actually want to fight excessive
debts with even higher debts
we are of the opinion that the
causes of the crisis must be tackled and
it is  the lack of
competitiveness and the insufficient
growth that means we believe
europe will
come forward again and
create jobs if we are more innovative, if we have more technology and if there are business start-ups again, i.e. if the framework conditions for
small and medium-sized companies
many people are getting better but are really scared about starting their own business,
for example in
bergen, the trade unions called for strikes there
,
we were there too, on monday
, social europe was forgotten,
that comes out of here, what are you
actually doing for these people who are now on
the streets, aren’t they?  only in france
as well as in germany so it's very
clear it can only be distributed what is
previously generated that means we
need competitive companies
with competitive jobs
that can then also
pay taxes and
duties on high incomes in order to finance social benefits
that means politics in france
constant tax increases has
forced companies to their knees has forced companies
to leave the country
we are now going to schuster it is
actually about the solution that is being
proposed
a professor asked this question from
the business school in
toulouse take out loans  for example, a solution would be,
i.e. invest in europe,
actually wrong at the time to get out of this
crisis into the future so it is crucial that if
you look at how much money is
available worldwide then there are private
investors who have money but they
don’t invest it in europe why the
markets are  saturated we are
not technologically at
the forefront the population is declining that means
the growth prospects in europe are
low
and to believe now you could finance that
with a declining population through
national debt that is extremely dangerous what i lack are investment programs and innovation programs that means for example galileo this  satellite
system that means, for example,
cooperation like the one we have in airbus strengthen
a successful european
company that is globally
competitive there
you naturally come back to one point
jean claude juncker suggests there 315
billion forints find 300 billion
again 2  1 billion
hannah in the purse at the moment not anymore
the european investment bank should actually
finance everything and
present everything that is done there
so i am glad that jean
claude juncker is launching a program for
infrastructure investments where
technology innovation can
be financed it should be through state guarantees
on the one hand but above all things  be financed through
the mobilization of private capital
that's right because
this capital should migrate elsewhere,
for example to asia the question is enough it's
quite here we notice the
european union is not a central state
it can help the member states but
the decisive impetus must come from
the states themselves  come and that's why
I don't
get enough talk about it in the current discussion, for example, you can
relieve the burden on the citizens in the reform countries by
reducing bureaucracy, which means less
complicated rules by giving them more
freedom, i think that's no way  nn
you can also save a lot of costs and
the right way was
the conversation